i don't know what i want to ask our next
guest about
more i know and and they're saying a lot
about
the fact that she's covering the los
angeles lakers
with lebron james on it and anthony
davis on it for the first time
she's also there covering the clippers
who have kawhi and paul george on them
correct
correct but i kind of want to know what
it's like to live in the bubble in
orlando like what's it like to live in
walt disney world for months i want to
know if she's gone fishing yet tanya
ganguly of the los angeles times our
neighbor just east of the rich eisen
show studio here in el segundo
california joining us from orlando
florida how are you tanya
i'm good i have gone fishing and i
caught five fish
i just wanted to start with that well
where does one where does one fish in
the bubble
is this a man-made uh situation a
human-made lake
that's right oh yes because disney world
is an entire
kingdom of artificial things for people
to do
there are several lakes here there's
there's a lake actually like on the
property where we live
um but we don't fish we didn't go
fishing in that we went to
the grand floridian which is the middle
tier of hotels
and they have a lake there and they took
us out on a pontoon
we actually did a i did the pontoon ride
the week before i went fishing and then
the next week
went fishing um and yeah they had a
guide with us he told us about
told us about the different things on
the lake and the gators that we might
see
and we didn't see any gators but i did
catch five fish i was the champion of
our boat
tanya way to take it down well done well
done incredible
um i i guess then there are you know it
we we could have a little bit more fun
with it but then this is a serious
issue obviously what's going on um
it seems like everybody's do you forget
about
uh what's going on in the real world at
all or
or what is what is it like do you feel
safe there
in in the bubble um i yes you feel
pretty safe in the bubble
it's um the nba has taken so many layers
of precautions
um but it's kind of you know there's
there's kind of like the
well well they they test you every
single day so you know that everybody
you are
coming into contact with has been tested
um it can't be a true bubble because the
people who work here
um they go home the the people who test
us they go home they leave the bubble
every night
and the people who work at the hotel
they go home
every night and they're in a place in
florida where
you know honestly like when i first got
here i was checking like florida numbers
every day and like trying to trying to
see what was happening in the state i
haven't looked in a while
um just because you know i'm here and
i'm
i will find out if i if i can track the
virus
i'll find out you know very quickly
because i have the luxury that a lot of
people don't have of
constant testing um so you know it's
i mean the bubble i think like what we
learned over the last few months is that
the bubble
the bubble system works um because they
can
you know because there's so much
surveillance and there's so i mean there
you have no freedom here to do anything
and that's that can feel very oppressive
but because but that's the really the
only way to
unless you're unless you're truly
quarantined that's really the only way
to make sure that
um that you're safe absolutely so okay
so the the people who are working to
keep the bubble afloat
by staffing the hotels and food and
and obviously the the things that you
need shelter uh
to to live they they are coming and they
are they are going
uh are you taking this um i'm fascinated
by this by the way because
it's so important for what's going on in
maybe
uh non-bubbled sports um and also
um maybe the uh whole country because of
what news came um in the last few days
that the fda has approved the saliva
test that the nba and yale have been
working on for this bubble is that the
test
that you take every day tanya well
i don't think so because they do it they
do an
oral swab and they do a nasal swab for
us
but it's not the deep um it's it's not
the deep
the deep nasal swab that they were doing
initially
so i believe that's a different test
from what we've been taking um
so far i don't know if that will change
because uh you know i'm gonna be here
for
exactly three more weeks i leave three
weeks from today um
and the uh delete you know the league
will obviously be here for
maybe two months maybe a little less
than that so um
i mean it's certainly possible that they
switch over to that eventually
so uh then let me get into this uh
next part of our conversation tanya
ganguly the los angeles times um let's
get into it
using that as a construct uh who leaves
the bubble first you are the lakers
tanya what do you think
i mean i i don't know
and that's really surprising i i mean i
think everyone's kind of assuming that
they'll figure it out they'll at least
get through this first round
um i'll be leaving in the middle of the
second round so
if they get through this first round
it'll be me but
you know portland has been i think what
was what was so interesting to me last
night is that there was never a point
where portland felt like they couldn't
win the game
and they there were so many different
moments where you thought well
i mean honestly like if this game were
at staples center there were so many
that series in the second quarter when
lebron had three
lebron had three uh three assists in a
row and it was a
quick eight no run and they hit two
threes which was shocking for that for
how they've been playing lately
um and you thought this is this is going
to turn the momentum now the lakers
they've hit a couple shots
they're gonna pull their confidence
together but it it just never happened
so
you know i think this bubble setting is
just so strange for everybody that
it's hard to know i remember when i came
in everybody kept asking me like what do
you think who's gonna win i was like i
have no idea
how everybody's going to react to this
setting because it
is i mean i know that people don't
really have sympathy for
nba players being in luxury hotels but
when you
can't leave when you when you're told
like this is where you're gonna be for
three months
that has a psychological impact um and
i'm not saying only the lakers are
dealing with it obviously everybody's
dealing with it but
i just felt like that was a variable
that people weren't considering enough
well i mean you want to talk about
variable uh bubble non-bubble
the lakers appear to be in the utmost
extreme here
and i'm just wondering if maybe this
game one loss might actually be the
wake-up call if that's necessary i mean
you've been around this team and you
have seen them but the numbers
do not lie uh the lakers when they were
uh playing in the nba as a home and away
team
had the best field goal percentage in
the league
and in terms of you know from the
regular field
second best two point field goals and
now
uh they have just been terrible i mean
they have been in the lower third
when we talk about tiers tier three of
the league
in virtually every possible scoring
percentage what gives
tonya what is happening yeah last and
three-point percentage
um i don't i don't know i mean it's
weird because we'll go around to all
these other teams and
they'll say oh these are shooters jen's
it's so much easier to shoot in here
doc rivers yesterday was talking about
how oh yeah it's crazy how the offenses
are all so far ahead of the defenses
right now
and that's just not been the lakers
experience they've been which which is
kind of like what you would expect you
would have expected that teams
you know after this long layoff that one
of the things that would take a little
time was shooting
um and offenses clicking together and
being able to work well together
um but that but you know for most teams
that hasn't
really come to fruition but for the
lakers it certainly has and i don't you
know they keep
there's really not hitting open shots is
really
i mean the answer to that is one day you
will i mean that's what the lakers keep
saying like well
we've done it before we believe in the
law of averages that's a big that's like
a big thing for them lately is
it'll eventually turn around but i mean
so far over the last
three weeks that they've been playing
there's not been any evidence
to support that well i guess that was we
were talking about it at the top of the
show tanya that um
that was one of the supposed fixes
that that got uh as a box that got
checked off
by the addition of danny green and so
many others
uh in this uh off-season that last year
they couldn't make an outside shot they
couldn't play defense but the defense
certainly has
vastly improved i mean they did hold
portland to 100 points
last night so uh so what is
what is i guess the mindset have you
been you being around this team
i mean what what do you think it is
for the los angeles lakers right now
tonya i mean that was the that was the
lowest percent that was the lowest
scoring total for the
trailblazers in the bubble like you
would think that i mean i think what
they were thinking is if we can play
if we can play defense like this we'll
be able to
win this game i mean there's there's
nothing to
there's nothing to say that they
wouldn't be able to do that so
um so it's it's
i mean i think i think they're you know
they had some
late defensive breakdowns that i think
they
they feel like they can correct um i
think they're looking at like small
things because the game was so close
um but you know it's it it's a very
it's very perplexing because someone
pointed out
yesterday like this is not the only team
that's dealing with
this that's dealing with this this
bizarre situation that's dealing with
not having their fans there
every team is dealing with that and
everything
you know there are some teams here who
don't play in front of huge crowds but
in the playoffs like most you know you
get that boost
and um i don't know it's something that
the lakers keep bringing up
and i wonder i would just wonder how
much that's impacted i mean
we're we're sitting at home and they're
pumping in fake crowd noise and stuff
like that and we're seeing you know the
fans uh virtually
are you like do you hear that in the in
the arena for the games or
are you just hearing sneakers squeaking
and that's it and people
yelling just like it's an empty gym is
that what if these guys are playing
so that was that was the case early on
the first couple of scrimmages
that's how it was and it was actually
kind of cool because you could see
you could like hear what they were
saying a lot better but but
now they pump in a lot of crowd noise
it's very loud in the gym
um they they did something cool too last
night where they would show every time
the lakers had a big play
they would show like footage of fans
from games at staples center and like
they did
like like past games and like they even
went back like there was one shot that
looked like it had to be from the 80s or
something
it was pretty cool to see and i would
have talked more about that in my game
story if the game had gone differently
um
no but this is interesting this is
fascinating because i guess in games
three and four are they going to do that
for portland
i'm serious like are they going to start
blasting stuff when portland makes a big
shot and things of that nature are they
doing that
now because i think i am again this is
the sort of stuff i notice
i do think that whoever is the home team
that whatever
you know um business deals they make to
get something on the floor
they they kind of check that box for the
home team i i
i and this is the this is to me
important to know because
if there's anything that would possibly
resemble
normal home court advantage for a team
in this weird bubble
um neutral sight playoffs that we're
seeing for the first time
i i imagine that if that's good for even
one call
one point that might that might mean
something you know
yeah yeah so they definitely do they
definitely try to create a home court
advantage
artificially so the the crowd noise does
it it fits with like like they'll have
they'll do the introductions at the
beginning of the game and the
the they'll get all the announcer who's
um olivier cedra
is the person doing it in the lakers or
in the arena that the lakers been
playing in
and he actually was the pa announcer in
cleveland when lebron was there
so there's like so he he does like the
pre-game
and they've sent they've actually sent
some audio of lawrence tantor
right sure they've done some audio of
him
saying certain things i think he does
the pre-game introduction
and some other things so like you're
going to try to create that
um they've they've done
you know they've they yes to answer your
question yes when when it's a portland
home game
it will be portland signage everywhere
it will be
the cheers will come when portland does
something good that
um you know like that that's all going
to change but you know what it
kind of backfired last night because i
don't know if you caught this moment but
um damian lillard hit a three to tie the
game at 87
and the lakers come back on offense and
dame
runs down he's standing right in front
of me and they start playing blow the
whistle by too short
and this song is an oakland song and
damian lillard is from oakland
and in the middle of the game he starts
dancing
just like he's like back on defense and
he just starts dancing and like
so you know it's like it i mean
how how could they have the person who
decided to do that song was probably
just like oh it's a nice beat it's a
good like
upbeat song for the lakers to come down
uh on offense to but it ended up being
this like
this like fun little moment for lillard
who just
i mean from that point on like the the
blazers really just took control of the
game well i read in your
in your post game uh in your write-up uh
in today's la times tanya ganguly here
on the rich eisen show i mean
you you quoted kuzma basically saying
hey you got to tip your cap this guy i
mean he is so
out of his skull right now and that's
the thing for the lakers
they're having trouble making shots when
they need it
that yes lebron is finding people wide
open and he's
i mean what a stat line it's it is
actually literally unprecedented his
stat line last night
and you've got an unconscious player
right now
unconscious who clearly is very
comfortable in the bubble
and i i would ask the poll question of
tanya please
uh go for chris brockman yeah tanya
which one seed uh should be panicking
the most the bucks the lakers
both or neither what do you think
i mean the bucks haven't looked good in
the bubble either um
but i i guess i would say the lakers
because
the way that they played last night is
how they've been playing in the bubble
so it's like until you see that that's
going to change and you know they're
confident it will but until you see that
that's going to change
you don't know that it will is rondo
um anywhere in the and they're facing a
better team
they're facing a better team the magic
are you know the magic
i don't think they really have home
court advantage even though they're in
their home market right now like
the trailblazers are not in an eight i
mean it's like cliche at this point to
say it but they are not an eight seed
what about rondo and anybody else j.r
smith waiters
just is vogel gonna start pressing a ton
of buttons or just
in rotation we trust what do you think
no he i mean rondo's rondo is close to
coming back he had a
he broke his thumb and he just got back
into the bubble a couple days ago
or he just got back out of quarantine a
couple of days ago um
so he they they want they want to play
him when he's back
um i keep getting reminded by like laker
fans really don't like lando
it seems um so um
there's mixed emotions about that but uh
but they
they really rely on him to be a settling
a settling presence
um that's that's really important for
them they feel like so
um you know that'll that'll happen i
could i can see dion getting some
minutes too
um so i don't think that what you saw
last night is
is like the end you know the end of the
story with how they're going to use
their rotation okay before i let you go
uh just to be fair and balanced the
clippers i mean kawhi
paul george there they are out there two
southern california stars now for the
los angeles clippers taking care of
business uh in game one against a very
talented young star uh in lucca uh
doncic and all
you know we assume porzingis will play
all four quarters in
in game two what did you take away from
the clippers
game one and their ability to take this
bubble down
yeah the clippers i mean the clippers
have been they look good
and especially when you consider the
clip for everything the clippers have
gone through
they had mantras hairline a minutes
limit they haven't really
throughout the last few weeks they
haven't had
many of their players like they've you
know they had
four guys have to leave because of death
of people close to them they've had long
quarantine googling had that long
quarantine
they're still kind of coming together
but um
they've been fine like they've you know
i thought i thought it was
it was pretty telling that they were
they were so close to the lakers despite
having
despite not having mantras harold lou
williams in that first
um the first game that they played
against each other so
um you know i i would feel really good
if i were the clippers
tanya thanks for the call appreciate it
stay safe um
we'll we'll call you again in short
order and um
see how many more how many more fish you
catch all right
i'll i'll keep a tally thanks for the
call that's tonya ganguly of the los
angeles times
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here